buenas tardes buenas tardes a todos
muchas gracias por la oportunidad es
realmente un honor poder estar aquí en
una plataforma de este tipo y aparte en
esta escuela al que le tengo tanto amor
para poder venir a platicar un poquito
de este tema que a mí me apasiona y creo
que ha sido muy muy claro el mensaje en
todas las pláticas previas que hay que
buscar aquello que nos gusta aquello que
nos apasiona y hacer lo que hay que
apostarle y que ahí es donde está la
felicidad del éxito como lo han venido
mencionando
él es mi abuelo él falleció ya hace
tiempo es una foto hace más de 30 años
empiezo con esta historia porque él me
inspiró él es el motivo por el que yo
estudié medicina originalmente siempre
salía desde chiquito más o menos de esa
edad que yo quería ser médico porque mi
abuelo era médico fue mi primera figura
paterna y entonces yo decía eso es lo
que yo tengo que ser de grande no sabía
porque más allá de esa noción muy básica
en su momento 23 años atrás
aproximadamente él se levanta con
humberto torres sanginés médico de
muchos años aquí de la comunidad
sintiéndose mal y pide que lo lleven al
hospital en la madrugada fallece en el
trayecto no llega al hospital no hay
nada que hacer por él
tenía en ese momento que se despertó
sintiéndose mal como un 1% de
probabilidad de librar esa noche
platicó esa historia porque vamos a
aterrizar la al final primero aquí les
voy a invitar a que se identifiquen con
alguno de estos tres grupos que estamos
viendo en la pantalla
estamos hablando de pacientes que se
dividen en los pro activos los sensibles
y los reactivos los prácticos son dos
aquellos que están en el doctor antes de
enfermarse están sanos y están
haciéndose un chequeo no y están
pensando que lo que le está pasando
enseguida le va a pasar a él entonces
mejor voy al doctor
después están los sensibles esos son los
que cuando empiezan a sentir molestias
de que hay traigo escurrimiento nasal o
traigo poquito a todos o algo entonces
empiezan a pensar en ir al doctor avanza
un poquito más la enfermedad y entonces
ya estando de alguna manera al inicio de
sus síntomas van al tor reciben un
tratamiento y se van a su casa pero no
toman más acciones en relación a su
salud
y luego están los reactivos son aquellos
que casi casi los están llevando en
ambulancia al hospital para que se
atiendan o bien tienen ya un mes con una
tos que dicen que esa alergia lo
realmente que mexicali es tuberculosis a
lo mejor no una situación así pero este
pero van al doctor
y ahora sí les digo internamente no
levanten la mano quienes están en ese
tercer grupo
excelente porque estadísticamente
estamos en ese tercer grupo y los
médicos como mi abuelo como un servidor
estamos en un cuarto grupo que se sale
de esa escala como los peores pacientes
creemos que a nosotros nos va a pasar
nada de eso o tenemos miedo de saber qué
es lo que realmente tenemos entonces nos
vamos al doctor pero a pesar de que la
mayoría estamos en ese tercer grupo la
realidad es que la expectativa de vida
ha ido aumentando y hoy en día está la
expectativa de vida excede los 78 años
en promedio si hubiera sido en 1850 y no
estaría casi a punto de fallecer
entonces sería mejor una despedida en
esta plática
pero afortunadamente así como el
cuadriciclo de ford el roadster de tesla
o del magic are valdearados
la medicina también evoluciona nos vamos
de la primera evolución digital de la
medicina que son los rayos x es cuando
empezamos a tomar esas fotografías para
ver una foto de un anillo que es la
señora röttgen se llama y es una foto
así súper irradiada o pobre señora este
pero fue la primera radiografía que se
tomó después llega una segunda evolución
digital cuando entra la tomografía
computada la resonancia magnética que
realmente son fotografías
tridimensionales del interior del cuerpo
y después no hace mucho tiempo la
tercera evolución es cuando empezamos a
capturar y almacenar grandes cantidades
de información de manera digital sean
imágenes notas médicas comentarios esta
información de artículos de ciencia
etcétera y los empezamos a acumular y
acumular y pues nos estábamos acumulando
porque al final del día pues para que
los borramos no
pero luego llega a esta cuarta evolución
que es el centro de la plática que es
cuando empiezan a entrar ya otras ramas
otras industrias y decir oye hay mucho
que se puede hacer aquí y hay un motivo
del por qué el vic deira la inteligencia
artificial el internet de las cosas vaya
la impresión 3d son cosas que
seguramente en diferentes carreras que
están estudiando actualmente posgrados
etcétera los han escuchado pero también
tienen aplicaciones en la salud en lo
personal como les decía yo estoy
apasionado con la tecnología yo tengo un
cepillo de dientes inteligente alarma
inteligente termostato inteligente se
todo está conectado no está tengo la lex
a no serán escuchados
jaime me dicen que eventualmente alguien
se pondrá celoso es alexa porque le pido
que haga todo no prende las luces apagan
las luces etcétera y todo eso lo único
que está haciendo es que está acumulando
datos y datos y datos con el objetivo de
hacer algo con ello y en la medicina lo
hemos estado haciendo pero realmente la
medicina ha estado muy concentrada en
los
médicos o en la gente que está de este
dentro de la industria porque
regularmente para ser médico y yo lo
viví pues tienes que llegar a la
medicina porque si no te dedicas a la
misión es porque seguramente eres mal
médico entonces ese fue un primer gran
barrera que se tuvo que brincar para
poder seguir en este rumbo porque tenía
yo que convencer a mis colegas que pues
estará otra área la medicina que tenía
algo de importancia alguien por ahí
mencionaba el doctor norton antivirus a
los que les tocó
y por qué porque es de suma importancia
en los últimos 20 años los servicios de
salud han aumentado más del 220 por
ciento esos en eeuu sin embargo el
ingreso por casa no ha aumentado más del
50 al 60 por ciento sin embargo muy
importante la tecnología a todo lo
relacionado con telecomunicaciones
computación software hace vuelto más
accesible en estos 20 años
esto implica que para poder pagar por
nuestra salud solamente hay tres
opciones el bolsillo de cada uno de
nosotros un seguro del gasto médico
mayor o bien una institución pública
pero la realidad es que ninguna de las
tres le alcanza ni siquiera la
combinación de los tres a veces es
suficiente y eso es porque como veníamos
platicando pues la mayoría estamos
enfermos a grandes edades y de cosas más
complejas cada vez
pero esto lleva a la siguiente idea eso
es donde estamos pero aquí es donde
queremos estar la medicina de las 4p es
no es un concepto nuevo tiene varios
años pero está teniendo mucho auge y
todo el mundo que viene a dar pláticas
de salud o de alguna manera lo menciona
porque nos habla de una medicina que sea
personalizada predictiva preventiva y
participativa es decir cuando decimos
una medicina personalizada nos referimos
a una medicina para latinoamérica o para
méxico para mexicalli o para el
auditorio del cetys sí sí no
la que es para ti o para ti o para mí
hecha específicamente y esto también nos
lleva a un punto adicional en la
prevención porque entonces ya la
prevención está individuo
individualizada para mí como yo puedo
evitar enfermar o participativa porque
te invito a que ahora tan
hiperconectados como estamos seamos
partícipes de esta planeación de nuestra
salud y predictiva
es que te pudiera pasar sino que te va a
pasar que se pueden crear algo modelos
que nos permiten de una manera u otra
decir a este presidente en particular va
a tener este problema si no toma estas
acciones lo va a tener no es probable
que lo tenga
chris taylor escribe un libro muy padre
que se llama la revolución del paciente
donde invita a que ella como alguien
ajeno al sistema de salud participe de
una manera nueva en reconstruir lo que
viene siendo como siempre se ha manejado
la salud la realidad es que los médicos
por su formación se han tenido que
dedicar a curar enfermos a curar
enfermedades entonces no pueden
concentrar su energía más que en eso
entonces ya dice bueno porque no lo
realizamos incluso vemos que están
haciendo otras industrias a nuestro
alrededor para mejorar esta situación
que hacen las aerolíneas para dar mejor
atención al cliente que hace la
manufactura para poder ver va a ser más
cantidad de piezas en un determinado
tiempo como disminuimos costos como
utilizamos software para poder dar a
bajar una parte de la atención como
acercó al paciente a un médico que está
del otro lado del mundo y ella dice
incluso que el paciente ya no debe
llamarse paciente sino que se debe
volver un consumidor de salud y entonces
tomar control
cada uno de ustedes cada uno de nosotros
en cómo quiere llevar su salud y al
final del día todo eso se resume en
mantener un paciente saludable sanz es
decir no curar una enfermedad sino si tú
ya estás sano dejarte en ese estado o
incluso mejorarlo
y pues eso es una foto de ciencia
ficción
reloj que está tomando te biométricos
que está conectado a tu celular que está
enviando esa información a la nube que
tu doctor está enviando información a la
nube y que toda esa información de
alguna manera está siendo utilizada y
colaborada para darte un beneficio
pues qué tan ciencia-ficción es esta
empresa por ejemplo arriba liderada por
un ingeniero se encarga de desarrollar
algoritmos de deep werning the machine
learning y de inteligencia artificial
para hacer detecciones oportunas de
cáncer en mastografías en donde el ojo
humano es insuficiente
entonces amplifica el poder del
radiólogo para hacer una detección
sábana es una empresa donde está un
médico un abogado y un ingeniero de
software desarrollando inteligencia
artificial para acompañar al médico en
la no también en la nota conforme la va
escribiendo ya asistiéndole en el
momento preciso no después de la
atención del paciente y no antes sino en
el momento que lo está viendo
y porque en la frontera porque de esas
tecnologías que parecen del otro lado
del mundo están aquí están aquí en
mexicano están aquí al alcance de todos
nosotros porque mexicalli como lo
mencionaban pues es un sitio rico en
turismo médico pues tenemos pacientes de
todas partes del mundo sobre todo de
eeuu tenemos sitios como esta
universidad que hacen grandes vínculos
para tratar de mejorar el intercambio de
ideas y el desarrollo de nuevas
tecnologías así que veamos que hay un
mundo más grande que mexicalli y la
comida china y opta enrique aquí las
carnes asadas sino que también puedes ir
hacer paella valència o puede decir este
hacer a lo mejor el que en china que es
lo que les gusta mucho hacer cuando van
de viaje pero bueno eso se lo dejamos a
juanjo pero es parte del efecto de estar
en este sitio tan privilegiado estos
compañeros ellos son egresados aquí de
cetys ingenieros ellos
ambos están desarrollando prótesis
biónicas para atacar un problema muy
grande del sistema
que es que estas prótesis valen cientos
de miles de dólares no setenta mil cien
mil dólares por lo menos entonces cuánta
gente tiene acceso a eso entonces vamos
a hacerlos aquí en méxico vamos a
hacerlos más accesibles y vamos a atacar
este segmento y no son médicos ninguno
de los dos
aquí estén cities el director de campus
mario team y trajo aquí a huanguelén que
fue parte del primer grupo de
mexicalenses en escalar el everest y ya
vi que alguien más lo mencionó hace rato
y precisamente yo estaba en esa plática
cuando lo trajo y es parte del mensaje
que les quiero dejar dejarse inspirar
también y él dijo algo muy importante
hay que emprender y hay que hacerlo
aunque no sea el momento ideal porque
ese nunca va a llegar pues hay que tener
el coraje de hacerlo dos que es muy
importante sentirte orgulloso de lo que
haces y dice yo tenía que aprender a
sentirme vamos a decir yo vendo lentes
pero el mejor para vender lentes aquí en
la zona y eso le permite hacer todas las
cosas que hacen su vida entonces de
alguna manera te dije bueno pues yo
también quiero ser estar muy orgulloso
dedicarme a las tecnologías en la salud
aunque sea médico y decirlo con orgullo
y lanzarte y estar dispuesto a fracasar
y literalmente el día siguiente de esa
plática para no decir que estoy haciendo
consejos que no tomó pues tomé esa
información esa enseñanza
multidisciplinaria que obtuve en la
universidad después de mi trabajo en
hospital mater y lo que estaba aprender
15 tis que viene aprender de lo que era
administrar realmente no como se debería
de ser hice una primera empresa la fundé
con mi socia que está insertada en el
auditorio hace cinco años y no se ha ido
muy bien y estamos resolviendo un
problema que tienen los médicos en la
industria de salud con principios que
tomamos de otras industrias aplicadas a
eso y eso lo menciono porque también
juanjo platicaba en una planta en una
clase en una base trata de emprender
sino también puedes emprender hacia
adentro no hacia dentro de una empresa y
ese principio lo llevé en mi trabajo y
hace cuatro meses pues tuvimos el gusto
de lanzar una aplicación que a lo mejor
yo espero que alguno de ustedes la tenga
en su celular sé que él cuando lo tiene
pero fuera de eso
es una aplicación desarrollada por un
equipo multidisciplinario donde se está
pensando en que queremos darle a la
comunidad para que estos principios que
practicamos de innovación de
participación de predicción y
personalización sean una realidad de
nuestra comunidad
aquí hay ingenieros de administración
perdón licenciados administración
ingenieros en sistemas ingenieros de
software ingenieros industriales
enfermeros radiólogos o sea toda la
plétora de
diferentes disciplinas unidas para
desarrollar esa aplicación y lo que
parecía ciencia ficción que decíamos hoy
es una realidad de aquí y aquí es donde
aterrizó esa historia que les decía
tenemos esta aplicación que ahora toma
esa información como lo mencionábamos
empieza a hacer cosas personalizadas
para cada uno de nosotros empieza a
empoderar los a todos ustedes a que
participen con su salud y la comparte
con el médico la comparte con el
hospital nosotros compartimos con
ustedes les desarrollamos iniciativas
para mejorar su salud para que se
mantengan sanos no nos quedemos en el
hospital los queremos sanos porque es
sano somos productivos y porque ese
cambio digital que tenemos hoy le puedo
reservar la vida a mi abuelo porque la
realidad es que cuando mi abuelo se
despertó él ya estaba con un infarto
fulminante y hoy en día o algo tan
sencillo como un reloj que podemos traer
te toma un electrocardiograma que es una
foto del corazón y el antes de haber
seguido
ese día hubiera sabido que se estaba
importando me hubiera ido al doctor y
ahorita yo casi los pueden apostar que
estaría aquí sentado con nosotros muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]